[Music]
in america there are many religions
and many gods millions of people want to
believe in something
so scores of mighty church organizations
offer them their services
the old and if one may say so the
european religions
suffer because of a certain abstraction
let them stay in europe on that old and
decrepit continent
in america side by side with skyscrapers
electric washing machines and other
attainments of the age
they somehow pale into insignificance
[Music]
los angeles in translation means city of
angels
yes it is a city of angels smeared
in oil here as in oklahoma city the oil
was found in the city itself and entire
streets are occupied by metal derricks
they tap pump make money los angeles is
a ponderous city
with large buildings dirty and popular
streets iron fire escapes which
stick out the facades of the houses this
is a california chicago brick
slums the realest kind of poverty and
the most revolting
wealth
we circled in our automobile around the
restaurant we had selected
without finding a place where we could
park our car looking for a place to park
we drove further and further away from
our restaurant migrating from street to
street
but the city was so full of automobiles
that we could not find a place for just
one more
little respectable mouse-colored
automobile
we drove to the very end where even the
noises of the city did not reach
and in the darkness we heard only the
roar of the ocean
here we finally parked and went to a
restaurant
we had to walk a half hour to it this is
what happens occasionally in a country
where there are 25 million automobiles
in the restaurant holding onto a fork of
a large piece of
pale christmas turkey mr adams solemnly
exclaimed
now gentlemen we have come to the very
end of the united states
we cannot go any further from now on no
matter what we do
no matter where we go we are going home
to new york
we have already driven 6 000 miles
hurrah
tired we got into our trusty automobile
which again
raced off with us the quiet roar of the
motor and the measured roar of the
gravel under our fenders
lulled us to sleep we drowsily shook
our heads and even mr adams became
thoughtful
but we were awakened from the silence
that suddenly overtook us
the machine was standing we discovered
that a hitchhiker was asking us to take
him
we took him and we were sorry at once he
talked
like a drunkard war is coming
he announced stuttering uninterruptedly
swallowing phrases and syllables
the young people want to fight they've
got to have something to do they need
some kind of work
work and fame there is no work the
machines have taken it from people
it wouldn't be a bad thing to destroy at
least part of those
accursed machines we'd heard this many
times by now
to set things right it was a good thing
to kill part of the people in war
and to destroy a part of the machines
then everything will again go smoothly
mexicans said our fellow traveler and
his drunken voice
like to live in dirt no matter how much
money they earn
they will always be dirty that's the
kind of people they are
give them five dollars a week give him
even five dollars a day
it will do no good it was easy for our
hitchhiker to live with such views
everything was easily solved part of the
people must be killed
part of the machines must be destroyed
and if there are any poor people
it is because they are a special kind of
people they
like to live in poverty all those
mexicans and poles
the south was approaching the last mile
separating us from louisiana we drove
through
forests the sun looked out it was warm
and joyous
as in the springtime in the ukraine
finally
we passed the little post with the
inscription state
of louisiana and raced alongside reddish
fields of harvested cotton
the monumental churches of the east and
the west were succeeded by wooden
whitewashed little churches on poles
instead of foundations
spanish and indian names were succeeded
by french names
we drove up to a large river in the
twilight it gleamed like metal
mississippi exclaimed mr adams
this is not the mississippi said mrs
adams calmly
this is the mississippi this is not the
mississippi
becky it depresses me to hear you say
that this is not mississippi
nevertheless it is not the mississippi
mr adams groaned
we drove across the bridge and found
ourselves in morgan city
before going off to look for a night's
lodging we stopped at a restaurant
called the blue goose
to have our dinner sir
asked mr adams of the proprietor winking
an eye
what is the name of that river i know
what it is but my wife would like to
know
this is the atchafalaya replied the
proprietor
sorry what atchafalaya
thank you very very much mr adams
backing out very very
it was only 100 miles to new orleans on
a sunny morning we started on our
journey
it was soft almost summery weather in
the course of several hours we met the
monotonous and
pathetic board huts of the black farm
workers
here was the devastating monotony of
limitless poverty
a kind of standard of poverty
in the dawless entrances almost falling
apart one could see not only no cows
pigs or chickens
but not even a wisp of straw this was
the very lowest stage of poverty
before which the picturesque poverty of
the indians may seem the height of
well-being
even of luxury this was in south united
states
in one of the most fruitful places on
the globe
[Music]
before us again appeared a large smooth
and completely deserted river
which reminded us of the vulgar although
perhaps not so broad
this is the mississippi said mrs adams
triumphantly
mr adams sighed heavily he would have
paid a high price that that river should
bear some other name
we were driving into new orleans new
orleans might have been called the
american venice
after all like venice it has risen out
of water if its innumerable canals had
not been hidden underground
in honour of the unseen canal the main
street is called canal street
it divides the city into two parts the
french which is
as careless as old paris with its little
streets its small arches on thin wooden
posts
it stores its restaurants of
unprepossessing appearance with first
class french cooking
it's port inns cobbled streets and
street stands filled with vegetables and
fruits
the beauty of which stands out
particularly thanks to the proximity of
dirt and slops thrown right out into the
street
and the new american part which adds
nothing to the character of the american
cities already known to the readers
[Music]
the further we moved through the
southern states the more
frequently we met with all kinds of
limitations designed for the black
population
sometimes there were separate comfort
stations or a special bench at an
autobus stop
or a special section of the streetcar
here even the churches were separate
for example one for white baptists and
another for the black baptists
when the baptist god several years hence
returns to earth
in order to destroy soviet atheists who
help one another
he will be delighted with his
establishments in the south of america
our further route lay along the gulf of
mexico through the states of louisiana
mississippi and alabama
we met black people with more and more
frequency at times for several hours at
a stretch we saw no white people
but in the cities the white man ruled
and if a black person appeared at some
moss-covered mansion in the residential
part
he would invariably have a broom a pail
or a package
all of which pointed to the fact that
here he could be only
a servant and yet the soul of the south
is its people not its white people but
it's black
speaking now of white people we have in
view these southern gentlemen
and not them only but also the gentleman
from the north who are likewise infected
with the psychology of slave owning
we also want to say that not all the
people in the south regard black people
as lower beings
but to our regret these are the majority
true to our rule to take into the
automobile people waiting for the
occasion on the road
at an isolated petrol station in north
carolina we picked up an 18 year old boy
from a ccc camp near washington
these camps had been built by president
roosevelt for unemployed young men
originally for six months
roosevelt hoped to end unemployment in
six months but
later when it became clear that it was
not so easy to end unemployment the
camps were left for an
indefinite period quite a cold rain
was pouring his story was ordinary
his father was a farmer the old man's
affairs were not so good the
boy graduated from a high school he
didn't have enough money to go to
college
he set out to look for a job he did not
find it
we were passing through a black village
you can tell a black man's house right
away from a white man's house
our fellow traveler said with a smile we
replied
how does it happen then that all the
black people are poor
i don't know about that is your father
acquainted with any black people
we know many and you treat them well of
course
would you ask such a black person to sit
down at the table with your family
the youth laughed no that's impossible
but why well because because black and
white people could not sit together at
the same table
but why not you must be from new york
said the young man to the southern mind
new york is the limit of free thinking
and radicalism
not only here but even in new york
itself about which the young boy from
the south talked with such horror
it is almost impossible to see a black
person in a restaurant
a motion picture theater or a church
unless of course he is there as a
servant a reporter
by law black people are free citizens of
the united states
yet in the south under various pretexts
they are deprived of the right to vote
and in washington itself and not alone
washington but in the very building
where the laws were written
the following occurred a black man by
the name of de priest was elected to
congress from the city of chicago
to the disaffection of the white
congressman he sat beside them
at the sessions of the house of
representatives
but that wasn't all this black man with
his black secretary
went to eat in the congressional dining
room he could not be turned out
and he paid no attention whatever to the
quiet demonstrations against him
finally they thought of an excellent way
out of the situation
they closed the dining room they closed
down
entirely the congressional dining room
just so that the black man would not be
able to eat
with the white people
and so after making ten thousand miles
we found ourselves
in the capital of the united states
washington with its comparatively low
government buildings its gardens its
monuments its broad streets
looks somewhat like vienna somewhat like
berlin somewhat like warsaw somewhat
like
all the capitals and only automobiles
remind one that this city is located in
america
here there is an automobile for every
two persons but there is not a single
permanent theatre
for the entire population of five
hundred thousand having
looked over george washington's house in
mount vernon having visited sessions of
congress and having been at the grave of
the unknown soldier
we discovered that there was nothing
else really to see
only the president remained to be seen
and in america
that is not so difficult
twice a week at 10 o'clock in the
morning the president of the united
states receives
journalists we managed to come to such a
reception
it took place in the white house
gradually about a hundred people
gathered
they smoked talked aloud and looked
impatiently at the small white door
behind which
apparently the president of the united
states was sequestered finally the door
opened and the journalists crowding each
other rushed ahead
we ran with the rest of them before us
in the depths of a circular private
study
on the walls of which hung old
lithographs depicting mississippi's
steamers
and in the small niches of which stood
models of frigates at a medium-sized
writing desk
a smoking cigarette in his hand and
chikovian ponce nay on his large
handsome nose
sat franklin d roosevelt
president of the united states behind
his back
twinkled the stars and stripes of two
national flags
questions began the correspondents asked
them the president
answered all of this ritual was of
course
somewhat conditional everybody knows
that the president will not disclose any
particular secrets to the journalists
certain questions the president answered
seriously and quite extensively
parried some with a jest it is not so
easy of course twice a week to get off
with a joke against a hundred pushing
journalists
distill others he replied that he would
discuss them next time
roosevelt's large handsome face looked
tired
only the day before the supreme court
had vetoed the aaa
roosevelt's law regulating farmer's
sowing of crops
one of the pivots of his program the
questions and answers took up to half an
hour
there resounded a helter skelter goodbye
mr president
and everybody departed and mr president
remained alone
in his circular study among the frigates
and the star-spangled banners
our journey came to an end
within two months we had been in 25
states and several hundred towns
we'd breathed the dry air of deserts and
prairies and crossed the rocky mountains
had seen indians had talked with the
young unemployed with the old
capitalists
with radical intellectuals with
revolutionary workers with poets with
writers
with engineers
we had traveled 10 000 miles
and throughout that entire journey we
never once stopped thinking
of the soviet union we had traveled over
american highways
but in our thoughts were soviet highways
we spent nights in american hotels but
we thought
about soviet hotels we examined ford's
factories but in our thoughts we saw
ourselves in our own automobile
factories and while conversing with
indians we thought
of kazakhstan it
is necessary to see the capitalist world
in order to appreciate
in a new way the world of socialism
the average american cannot endure
abstract conversations
nor does he touch upon themes too far
removed from him
he is interested only in what is
directly connected with his house
his automobile or his nearest neighbors
he shows an interest in the life of the
country once in every four years
at the time of the presidential election
we do not at all insist that this
absence of spirituality is an organic
attribute of the american people
it is capitalism that has made these
people thus
and in every way it nurtures in them
this
spiritual latitude terrible are the
crimes
of american capitalism which with
amazing trickiness is palmed off on the
people the most trivial of motion
pictures
radio and weekly journalistic tosh while
reserving for itself
tolstoy van gogh and einstein
but remaining profoundly indifferent to
them
at the foundation of life of the soviet
union
lies the communist idea we have a
definite goal
toward which the country advances
america
does not know what will happen with it
tomorrow
we know and we can tell with definite
accuracy
what will happen with us 50 years from
now
and we can say honestly with hand on
heart
that we would not like to live in
america it is interesting to observe
this country
but one does not care to live in it
in new york we boarded the steamer the
huge bulk of the majestic
had already left the pier and we heard
for the last time
goodbye gentlemen seriously i hope that
you have understood
what america is and over the heads of
the people at the pier
frantically waved the trusty old hat of
mr adams
and the handkerchief of his wife who
twice drove us across the entire
continent
the never tiring patient ideal fellow
traveller of the road
when the majestic sailed past wall
street darkness fell
and lights appeared in the skyscrapers
and those windows gleamed the gold of
electricity
but perhaps also real gold
this last golden vision of america
escorted us
to the very egress into the ocean
the majestic gathered speed the farewell
light of a boy flashed by
and a few hours later there was not a
trace left
of america the cold
january wind blew a large ocean wave
[Music]
you